hi there Steve Kaufman here again
answering some of the questions that you
have written on my YouTube account I
apologize for this light on my head
shining off my gray hair or white hair
but if I don't put the light on then
it's too dark in here so hopefully that
doesn't disturb you first question was
what is your motivation to learn new
languages this came from a person in
Spain and another person asked something
about why are you learning Ukrainian I
think and I mean the motivation can be
you know anything right now the
motivation to learn polish is because I
speak other Slavic languages or I have
learnt them and studied them so I'm
curious to see how polish works and of
course every time you learn a language
you learn so much about the country so
and people ask me about what about you
know Arabic or Hebrew and yes I'm
motivated to learn those particularly
Arabic because there's so much history
behind that language and because so many
people in the world speak it so a lot of
my motivation is is is cultural interest
in the country and I want to learn about
different different people different
cultures in different parts of the world
the next question was how do you keep a
language fresh in your mind how do you
not lose vocabulary in my experience if
I learn a language through massive
listening and reading massive exposure
to the language I tend not to lose it
but the way i refresh it is that I just
do more of the same listening and
reading so and now that I have link it's
particularly good so I can go in and do
some Chinese for example and and in fact
I think the person who asked this
question was afraid that they were
losing their Chinese vocabulary so I'll
go through and maybe find something on
the internet or I might just get an
audiobook and and find the e-book and
bring it in and listen and then read and
save words that I need and I find that
that very quickly refreshes my grasp of
that language next question was how do
you study grammar and someone
specifically asked about all of the you
know daya
them.these whatever D in German how do I
study it well historically what I did
was I would do a lot of listening and
reading and occasionally referred to
grammar explanations in the hope that
that helped me notice it and therefore
get used to it
now I'm kind of interested in this whole
approach that I've mentioned before
filters 100 stories where he tells the
same story and then asks so many
different questions that you are in fact
reviewing the different structures using
very limited vocabulary covering the
same ground over and over again with
different questions in different answers
and that made us be more efficient than
trying to remember tables which I've
always found very difficult to do
another person asks how do you find
stuff to write about it's difficult if
you're in a school or in a classroom you
are assigned writing if you have to
motivate yourself to write it's more
difficult what you can try doing is
something that Luca does look at who is
a very accomplished polyglot and he
translates from the target language into
his own language and then back into the
target language so if you grab a
sentence of something you're reading
translated back into your own language
and then try to write it again in the
target language another person asked you
know polyglots they claim to speak many
languages but how many languages can
they really speak well well if you
listen to Richard simcard or look up to
name 2 specifically I would say they
speak extremely well in at least half a
dozen languages in my own case certainly
it's true that my strongest three or
four are stronger the next three are ok
and then as you work your way down then
I don't speak them so well and I think
inevitably anyone who is a polyglot is
going to have a handful of languages
that they speak very well another
handful that they speak ok and others
that they don't speak so well however
it's possible that there are
polyglots out there who have you know
who devote more time to it and who can
actually maintain a high high level in
more than a handful of languages a
question I get all the time is how do
you spend your time how much time do you
spend I would say I'm down here in Palm
Springs now my we're down here because
my wife likes to play golf I prefer to
play hockey in the winter if it were me
I would be still up in Vancouver
so we play golf most days and then
there's other chores and stuff but I
think I put in an hour or two a day with
my language a good hour of that is
listening I recently had to go to three
stores to buy stuff I went to Home Depot
and then I went to Walmart I went to
Target buying different things for the
house here and the whole time I'm in the
car I'm listening I also sat down with
my iPad and then did some of kilcher's
stories for good half-hour I also in the
evening will sometimes go through my
polish history creating links when I do
the dishes and clean up I'm listening so
I think I get in an hour to do two two
hours a day and that's how I managed to
do it by combining it with other
activities am i interested in Dutch sure
we have Dutch adlink but the difficulty
is I'm interested in Dutch I'm
interested in Arabic I'm interested in
Turkish I can only do one at a time so
one day maybe I have done some lessons
of Dutch at link and it doesn't strike
me as being very difficult question was
what do you find difficult with Korean
I've gone over this before the
difficulty is finding you know
interesting content that's not too
difficult a lot of words when you look
up the dictionary the online dictionary
it seems that a lot of words mean the
same thing it's it's of course it's
written in Hangul so it's not written in
the Latin alphabet that's always it
makes it always a little more difficult
when you're reading in that you know
alphabet or a writing system that you
haven't been using all your life so
those are some of the things I don't
know really why I have just found Korean
to be differ
I am continuing another question here
was a person studying Chinese should I
learn to write from the beginning and
absolutely especially that he'll Organa
katakana and you should I recommend for
Asian languages to learn to write the
characters if they have characters and
finally there was a question on how do I
develop my academic English or my
ability to write in an academic way and
to me there's no difference between say
English business English academic
English and the other kind of English
you have to go and find content
interesting content on the kinds of
subjects that you want to develop an
ability to write and speak in so
academic English if you feel this
medicine or chemistry or physics you go
find on the internet or whatever source
you have content ideally both audio and
text if you can find it and you just
read lots of that and I would recommend
doing it that link where you can save
key phrases the kind of phrasing the
people in your field are using and you
just acquire the vocabulary and the
phrasing of people in that field and
there's nothing special about academic
English versus being a business English
or any other kind of specialized jargon
and specialized terminology you just
have to acquire it and make it part of
your first of all vocabulary that you
understand and ultimately vocabulary
that you can use so there you have it I
apologize for the light you know one
thing I am going to talk about in my
next video is Mark Zuckerberg who made a
20 minute presentation in Chinese in
Beijing I was quite impressed and I'm
gonna give him some suggestions on what
he could do to be even better but
that'll be in the next video so thank
you for listening bye for now